[MUSIC PLAYING]
VINAY BALASUBRAMANIAM:
Good afternoon, everyone.
Thanks for coming.
So let's get started.
So how many of you attended
the keynote session today?
Awesome.
Lot of great announcements
today, especially
in the data analytics space.
This session is going to focus
on two key announcements which
is BI Engine and
connected Sheets.
So we're going to go deeper into
why we built BI Engine, or what
is the value proposition, what
is connected Sheets offer.
And we'll have a customer,
AirAsia chief product officer,
Nikunj Shanti, who is going
to show a demonstration of how
BI Engine and connected Sheets
has helped AirAsia become
a data focused organization.
So let's get started.
So if we look at the BI today,
business intelligence today,
it's still a critical workload
for a lot of organizations.
A lot of key day
to day decisions
depend on access to
business intelligence tools.
It's harder for IT to manage
and scale business intelligence
infrastructure.
There are a lot of
vendor solutions,
and every department has their
own solutions to do this.
And it makes it very
hard for them to scale--
make sure all the data
is available on time--
to do that.
And this statistic shows
that about 24%, back in 2009,
had access to BI tools
within the organization.
And since then it has
grown to about 35%
of its self-service BI,
but still there is a gap.
And we have heard this from
customers of BigQuery today.
Lot of customers who
use BigQuery today
still have to take the
data out of BigQuery,
create a data
mart, run extracts,
or manage a BI server,
to do their reporting
and dashboarding.
The second thing
is customers want
us to have fast,
interactive, experience
for their dashboards.
Sub-second query latency, so
they can visually interact
with the data, make decisions.
And the same time, they also
want access to fresh data,
so they don't want to compromise
between data freshness
and speed.
They want to have
access to real time data
so that decisions
can be made on time.
And, lastly, customers
want to expose those data
sets, the key metrics
to broader set of users
within the organization.
So, BI is more
available to more users
so they can get
access to data sets.
How many of you
used Sheets today
or some sort of spreadsheets?
So this recent study
done by the Sheet's team
shows that Sheets are still a
top dog within the enterprise.
Lot of users use Sheets as a
way to do lightweight business
analyst, business intelligence
analysis, and lightweight data
wrangling.
And really the opportunity
we have in front of us
is to really fill this gap.
So BI becomes lot more pervasive
within the organization.
A lot more users have
access to BI tools,
as opposed to getting restricted
to some sort of few users
within the organization.
So this is built on
what Google believes in.
Google believes in organizing
world's information
and making it accessible.
And we believe that we want
to have the same experience
with business intelligence.
We want to offer the
first party experience
with their Studio and Sheets,
at the same time support
partner solutions
like Tableau, Looker,
so customers have the
choice which they can
use for business intelligence.
We want to enable BI on
big data so that customers
can explore big data sets
but without compromising
on scale or speed.
Collaboration is a
big part of what we
do with business intelligence.
We want to make sure customers
can share the data set securely
within the organization
with their partners,
with their vendors,
without having to worry
about security challenges.
And, lastly, this
notion of blending
AI and machine learning
into BI so that you could do
predictive analytics, is key.
I was talking to
a recent CIO who
didn't have a good handle
on the BI infrastructure,
but he said, if I put ML,
everything will become easy,
I can do predictions,
but that's not true.
Because you need to have a
solid foundation of business
intelligence from a data
management perspective;
otherwise, you're going to
make a lot of bad decisions,
but you will be doing it
with more confidence, right?
So you want to make sure
that BI is the foundation
layer on which you can layer
machine learning and AI.
If you look at our reference
architecture with GCP,
we have simplified solutions
across all different phases
of BI, right?
From ingestion, whether
you're ingesting
from on-premises sources,
or cloud sources,
we have a bunch of
different set of products
which allows you to do
different ingestion experience.
For example, we have Dataflow,
we have Cloud Data Fusion--
which we announced today,
which is about ETL--
we have Big Data Trans--
BigQuery Transfer
service for SAS
connectors, we have
Dataproc and we have a bunch
of partner solutions as well.
All the data goes into BigQuery,
which is our petabyte scale
data warehouse, on which we
have data catalog for metadata
service, and we have data
prep for data wrangling.
From there, you can query the
data set using BigQuery cycle
interface, or use Data
Studio Sheets, and also
partner solutions like
Tableau, Looker, et cetera.
But our goal is to make business
intelligent infrastructure
management easy so
that it's invisible,
so you can focus a lot more on
asking questions, interacting
with your data set in a
much more faster manner.
So, today, we announced
BigQuery BI Engine.
And BigQuery Bi Engine
is really helping users
to have the scale which they
expect in a BI scenario.
So, in this, the key goal
with BigQuery BI Engine
is to democratize BI so that
your data analyst and business
analyst can do real-time
interactive analytics at scale
without having to compromise
on data freshness, or speed.
So BigQuery BI Engine
is an in-memory engine,
in-memory analysis engine,
which is built into BigQuery.
So that allows you to do
sub-second query responses
for some of your business
intelligence queries
at high concurrency.
So some of the key aspects
of BigQuery BI Engine is that
sub-second queries--
it simplifies the
architecture, now
you don't have to move
data outside of BigQuery
to any of your data marts
or run complex extracts.
It's built into BigQuery.
And, lastly, it has
some query optimizations
done for some of
the BI use cases
so that your queries are
really optimized as you
start scaling your dashboards.
So let's go into each
of them individually.
So sub-seconds queries.
So BI Engine is a column
oriented in-memory analysis
engine built into BigQuery.
BigQuery is a column
oriented data store,
and BI Engine is a column
oriented in-memory engine.
It can scale horizontally
so as more users access
your dashboards and reports.
It can replicate data
horizontally to multiple nodes.
So it can support all the
concurrent queries much more
faster.
And the last one is
an important one.
BigQuery BI Engine
natively integrates
with BigQuery streaming.
So, as data gets streamed
into your infrastructure,
into your BigQuery table,
it can do aggregation right
on the streaming buffer,
so your total latency
from the event coming into
BigQuery versus showing up
in your dashboard is in
seconds, not minutes or hours.
So that sort of makes the
whole real-time experience
for dashboards much more faster.
Second one is it's built
on BigQuery storage,
and because of which
it eliminates the need
for managing any BI servers,
or running extracts, or running
a data mart.
It automatically decides what
kind of data sets to be used,
and it automatically loads it
into an in-memory OLAP cube.
So you don't have to really
create any OLAP engine
or manage that.
We sort of create a super
fast OLAP cube on the fly
and then expose that
to your dashboards.
And our key goal here is
also to be open to partners,
so we'll have an open API,
which is a simple SQL interface,
so that tools like
Looker, and Tableau,
or any of the open source
tools, can connect to BI Engines
through SQL interface and
still get the same experience.
A last one is smart tuning.
So BI Engine has
a query optimizer
built in which looks at
your BI specific query
and optimizes that.
For example, it uses the
right sort of encoding,
it understands what
sort of queries
you're using so it
can do compression,
or it may not do compression
based on your group by
or other clauses.
And lastly, all of this capacity
management for BI Engine
is built into BigQuery
UI starting today.
So if you go to
BigQuery UI, you will
see a new option
called BI Engine where
you can decide how much capacity
you need for your BI use cases.
So it automatically takes all
those columns, which you create
from Data Studio, loads it into
memory, and any of the data
queries which come from
Data Studio itself,
from the BI Engine video,
we don't use BigQuery slots.
So you sort of
make good trade off
between what kind of
concurrency or query latency
you need versus how many
slots you want to use.
So you can make this
seamless trade-off
based on your use case.
And it's as simple as going and
deciding how much capacity you
need for the project,
and then it automatically
does that for you.
And all these metrics
about how much
data is coming from BigQuery
OLAP cubes is all surfaced
in Stackdriver so you can
see what is a query latency,
you can decide how
much of it's coming
from the in-memory
engine, was a slot
so you can decide
how much capacity you
want to add more versus reduce.
So let's look at--
a quick look at
BigQuery architecture.
This is the BigQuery
architecture today,
which we have shared
with you for all years.
It's really what makes
BigQuery a petabyte scale data
warehouse is the separation
of storage and compute
with a better word network
which makes what BigQuery is.
But what we are adding
today, with BI Engine,
is a stateful execution layer
on top of the same BigQuery
storage.
The stateful execution
layer actually
maintains the state
of all your data sets,
so that when you access
that from a dashboard tool,
like Data Studio or Sheets, it
can do the smart optimization
in-memory versus going
back to BigQuery storage.
And it can automatically
maintain this adaptive cache
between the storage layer
and the in-memory layer.
So let's go one level
deeper and see how it works.
So behind BI Engine there
is a semantic model.
So we create a semantic model
comprising of your metadata.
It has a calculation API,
which Data Studio uses today,
and it maintains all that
semantic model in memory,
and when the query comes the
intelligent memory manager
looks at the query, and looks at
what optimizations can be done.
And if it can be done
within the in-memory layer,
it actually does all
those optimizations
like picking the right encoding,
picking the right compression
format, and solves
that from the query.
And it cannot-- if
it doesn't do that,
it automatically
fails over to slots.
So it automatically decides
what kind of optimization
can be done, it'll do it.
If not, it'll use slots.
And that's what makes the
initial sort of small queries
much more faster.
When I'm talking about
millisecond latency
is what you get
from this engine.
So how is the pricing for this?
The pricing is very similar to
how BigQuery's priced today.
There's a on-demand tier
and there's a flat tier.
So, for on-demand,
it starts at 1 gig,
and you can add in
increments of 1 gig capacity.
And it's about
$0.0416 GB per hour,
or it roughly translates to
$30.36 per gig, per month.
And I said earlier, whenever any
query comes from the BI Engine
capacity, we don't use
slots, so you're not
paying for the per query cost
that you see in BigQuery.
So you make those trade-offs
based on your use case.
And if you're a
flat rate customer,
we pre-bundled the BI Engine
capacity for every tier.
So if you are a
400 slot customer
we give you 25 gigs of capacity.
If you're a 2,000 slot tier, we
give you 100 gigs of capacity.
And if you want
anything more, you
can pay based on the per
gig cost, which is on--
which is on the left side.
So, today, in beta,
we are not enabling
billing so you can experience
BI Engine for your use case
up to 10 gigs.
You can try it out, see how
it works for your use case.
But once we start enabling
billing sometime in July,
we will increase the capacity
so you can get bigger capacity
sizes as well.
So we've been using BI Engine
for working with customers
for last few months, and
we've got some great feedback
and it has helped us improve
this whole engine as well.
So Vendasta is a customer
I met at Next last year.
We're doing a session
on how billing--
how showing the billing
dashboards in Data Studio--
I noticed they were a
little slower to load.
So we worked with them and
got them on to the BI Engine
alpha program.
They worked with us, and
since then it has dramatically
changed the way that
dashboard latency are, right,
from minutes to-- it has come
down to literally seconds.
And they're slowly
going to roll out
this to their internal
users and as well as
to the end customers.
So we see that success
with Zalando as well.
So Zalando is a e-commerce
leader in Europe.
So they had this internal
supply chain dashboard
which all of their suppliers
use to look at their use cases,
how much goods are being
sold on their website,
what channels are effective.
And they wanted that very
interactive experience
for their business stakeholders
and product managers
to make those decisions.
By using the BI
Engine, they were
able to get to that
level of quality latency.
And they were able to roll
it out to a set of users,
and today they have about 800
users within the organization
using Data Studio, and
they're going to expand that
to a lot more users.
Again, going back
to democratizing BI
and making it accessible
to a lot more users.
Last one is a Fortune
500 media company.
And they sort of create--
sort of a news data warehouse
for their journalists
and editors, so
that they can look
at what channels are
being used, and what
is the more effective way
to market their news pieces.
So they provided a
dashboard on Data Studio
to their internal users
running on BI Engine,
and they were able to get a
lot more faster experience
for their users.
So, with that, I also
want to introduce
the next piece of democratizing
BI is connected Sheets.
So connected Sheet is a way
you use Sheets as an interface
but, it's backed by BigQuery.
So it maintains a live
connection with BigQuery.
So you've got any
knowledge of SQL--
with minimum
knowledge of SQL-- you
can just drag and drop,
create pivot tables,
do filtering, apply formulas,
with just few clicks.
And because of the
whole G Suite experience
of sharing and
collaboration exposing,
and share securely your
sheets with lot more users
within the
organization, so that we
don't have to worry about
exporting data to a sheet
and giving it to different
people or emails.
You can do that securely.
But since it's
backed by BigQuery,
it can do analysis
on a large data set
which was not possible earlier.
So we're super excited
about connected Sheets.
Again, we'll have beta
sometime in end of 2019,
and at that point
connected Sheet will also
BigQuery BI Engine as
their underlying engine.
So you get the same experience
of subsequent query latency
on a big data set with the
interactive experience,
so that you can roll out your
BI use cases to a lot more users
within the organization.
So with that, let
me introduce Nikunj.
Nikunj is the Chief
Product Officer of AirAsia,
and they've been a great
advocate of BigQuery,
and they've been using all
our early versions of product
and given us great feedback.
So with that, let me hand
it off to him to showcase
how BI Engine and
connected Sheets
has impacted his organization.
NIKUNJ SHANTI: OK, great.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
So a little bit of
background, AirAsia
is a low cost airline
based in Southeast Asia.
We're in our
transformation program.
We're working on AirAsia
3.0, which is really
about taking the airline
to the next level, which
is more than beyond flights.
It is really about
selling customers
other things that
they might need
in their journey such
as hotels, activities,
and other complimentary things
that go beyond the flight.
And to do that, we
have to really become
a digital airline, really
leverage the data that we have.
Over the history
of AirAsia, we've
flown over 500
million passengers,
and we want to start going
on to the next experience
of personalizing their
experiences in booking ticking,
uh, booketing and ticketing.
And then the second thing is
really in the airline world
you still see a lot
of paper being used.
It's about digitizing
that paper so we
can do a lot more data
flows across the board
and complete the data loop.
So we'll talk a little bit
about that as we go on.
But the whole goal is to
get AirAsia to AirAsia 3.0,
which is really around
going beyond flights
and selling other opportunities.
And so, just a little bit
of background on AirAsia.
We're a very, very large
airline group in Southeast Asia.
Number four by numbers in
Asia, 260 aircraft, 360 routes,
90 unique destinations.
So unique means that we're the
only ones flying that route
which gives us a great view
on where customers want to go.
140 destinations
in 24 countries.
We fly around 90
million passengers,
so, as you can imagine, that's
a lot of personal information,
but also a lot of
information about customers
that don't actually book
and transact with us,
but we have a lot of
detailed information there.
And over the lifetime we
have 500 million customers,
and our staff is quite
intensive as well.
We have 24,000 staff
which we call AllStars.
And so, as AirAsia is going
through the next trajectory,
we're transforming
from an airline company
to a digital company,
and technology and data
is quite important for that.
We're trying to build a brand
that will go beyond ASEAN,
and we have a five-year
plan for Asia 3.0,
which is really to
go beyond flights.
And then we want to be
leading the pack on innovation
and pioneering, so we're really
using data as a key lever
to be able to do that.
And we'll talk a
little bit more on how
that works within AirAsia.
So in terms of data,
we've been collecting
data for a long time.
There's so many places that
you can collect information.
You can kind of see how
that is listed out here.
There's always emails, loyalty
programs, the actual ticketing,
booking, profiles of
customers for what they like,
what they don't
like, do they like
to buy a seat--
we sell a La Carte
seats, meals, bags-- so we
have a lot of preferential data
on what customers like.
And, based on the routes, we
see a lot of different behaviors
that are happening,
and we want to be
able to use that data to help
personalize what's going on.
We have social media
activity, with the invent
of mobile we have a lot
more on location tracking,
and how people are using--
as you can imagine,
people that book on mobile have
a different profile than people
that book on desktop.
So we're taking advantage
of all that data.
We spent a lot of time
for the last three years
really normalizing and putting
all that data into BigQuery
to be able to build
that foundation so
that we can make really good
use cases come out of it.
And some of those are
really turning out anew,
and I'll talk about
a couple of them,
that the team are working
on, that really help
for our operations as well.
So there's a couple
of folks working
in a couple of use cases
around meal planning and things
like that.
And then all of this really--
our end goal is really--
to collect information
throughout the whole journey
as much as possible.
We're very guest obsessed,
we want to really drive
our guest experience higher.
And our goal is to have
a really high NPS score,
and we're using all these
different touch points, really
completing the data loop.
As you can imagine,
many, many airlines just
focus on one part
or another part,
we want to really
focus on the end
to end journey and really
capture all feedback
and experience that happens.
When people are just
doing discovery,
which is before search, but also
when they come to the website--
where are they searching
for, how many times
are they searching, how do
we make this a little bit
better and faster, how do we
market the right information
to customers.
So we really need a
really solid foundation
to be able to collect that
data, and BigQuery is really
provided us that foundation
and, based on that,
we're able to customize
and do a little bit more
beyond on the search side but
also on the operation side
that we're working on there.
And then from the
data management
to data driven outcomes, right?
So we have a lot of
data that comes in.
We have descriptive
analytics, which are really
around business intelligence
and reporting, which
is standard what
most companies have,
and where we're
making it a lot easier
and trying to
democratize that data.
So I'll show you
some of the examples
that we have with Data
Studio and in Sheets,
connected Sheets,
how that works.
We have some other
situations, on the left,
on diagnostic analytics,
which is really around
how to improve the operations
or how to sell more.
We're working on what might
happen, which is around--
do we put extra meals on a plane
or do we keep the amount there.
Because every time
we put extra meal,
we think we might
be able to sell more
by just doing more
announcements, and et cetera,
but that's not always the case.
And can we use ML to
be really optimize
our wastage on the plane, to
get some really good examples
and use cases beyond
that, and then
what's the next best action.
So, depending on your
demographic and your profile,
if you're flying a
short haul flight that's
only less than 75 minutes, would
you really want to buy a meal,
or would you be more interested
in boarding and leaving
that plane first.
And so, based on
that information,
we can make different
techniques and status
based on your preferences and
also show different results
to a user on a website.
So we've incorporated all
those type of techniques
onto the website.
So if you do use
AirAsia.com, you'll
see many of those things.
And if you're on a plane
that's being leveraging a ML
model for food, you'll
see that the food wastage
is very low on that
plane because we're
able to ensure that we don't
have extra weight because
of the food, but extra--
we're not losing money
because of the wastage share.
So that's all being
taken care of.
So we're really using
our data and trying
to drive outcomes
that come out of it.
And so the key things
that happen on the AirAsia
transformation is really--
we want to-- like I mentioned
before, the airline has
a lot of paper processes.
So we need to go ahead and
digitize that information.
Once we start digitizing
the information,
we can start to see
patterns, right?
And we can really start
making minor adjustments to it
and to be able to go
optimize that stuff.
So, as part of that
transformation,
we've gone through
organizational changes
to enable that process.
We've started to move a lot
of our data to the cloud.
Once the data is
in the cloud, we
can do a couple of
automations to really check
on our hypotheses and see
if that's really happening.
We move to agile structure
so that commercial teams,
and marketing teams,
and technology teams,
are really moving quicker and
being able to produce outcomes
and really--
instead of taking
months to do something,
we can do something in weeks
to see if our hypotheses are
working correctly.
And then we do it again.
So it's a full circle process.
If we find something else,
we continue to process there.
And why do we chose--
or choose Google Cloud Platform?
Well, back when we
started the journey,
BigQuery was the leader
in the space back then,
and still is the leader now
in terms of processing data
subsection queries.
Actually, getting information
into BigQuery is very
straightforward and I'll talk
a little bit about that one-.
And cost, as a low cost airline,
cost is quite important for us
in being able to decouple query,
and storage is quite important.
And then the NoOps
model of BigQuery
is great so that our developers
can go ahead and develop
infrastructure, or data
sets, but also ETL processes.
So they don't have to worry
about an infrastructure
guy who's spinning up a new
database, that's not a problem.
And then being able to do many,
many queries in background,
so they're not waiting for
whose priority of the query
goes first, right?
That's not a problem anymore.
That was a problem
that we had before.
And so all of that is solved
by the Google Platform.
But as we develop more
and more things on Google,
all the data sits in one
place, and then we're
able to combine it in BigQuery
to be able to do a lot more use
cases.
All right?
And so our solution architecture
here is built this way,
and I'll walk you
through a little bit more
so you understand how it works.
We have a RDBMS--
I think most customers
have RDBMSs out there--
our RDBMS is a very old Windows
technology RDBMS, I'll say,
and we need to get
the data out of there.
And so we have some connectors
with the ETL over here,
in the middle we use
Composer, in that scenario,
to get data out of there
and we load into BigQuery.
We have flat files that come
out for many of the third party
data that we have when we're
doing pricing comparisons.
We use third party
acquisition sources
and we get some data from there.
Again, that goes
through a Pub/Sub
so that we can automatically
load it into BigQuery
via a notification.
We have data from Firestore,
for our NoSQL data,
and that goes through
Cloud Functions whenever
updates happen, so that
goes into BigQuery,
and any other data
that's automatically
produced from GCP.
So our App Engine logs, and
other things around there,
we can go ahead and
actually put into BigQuery,
and it makes it a lot easier for
us to have a centralized place.
And then what we do from there
is really have some processes
on Cloud Functions, or
Composer, or other scripts
that we have that really start
massaging that data into data
marts that we need, or
big data lake in BigQuery,
so we can start looking
at individual profiles.
So we can look at
the individual user
and see their
history and pattern,
if you've logged
in, to understand
what we need to personalize.
Or we go ahead and
do attribute scoring
that we need to
do to provide you
a route, what that route really
wants, or an example of cart
loading is based on who's
flying, what type of meals
might be needed to sell that.
All of that goes into BigQuery.
And, for archiving purposes, we
store a snapshot of every day
into Cloud Storage, so if
we want to roll back in time
and see what happened, we
can go back and go load
up that snapshot from
Cloud Storage so that--
a lot of times things,
as you can imagine,
the airline is a moving state
operation and things that
were the status three
weeks ago might not
fit the status of a ticket.
And you don't want to--
you don't want to store a
live repository of that-- we
can just go snapshot in time and
see what that ticket state was
a couple of weeks before and
see what's happening there.
Now, all of that actually goes
into our delivery and digestion
insights delivery.
We have two primary tools,
Data Studio and Sheets.
And, recently, we've
been able to cut down
on some of the other
tools that we use--
just the products have
gotten so much better--
and they are
continually improving.
And they are helping us reduce
our dependency on third party
tools.
So we have Data
Studio and Data Sheets
on that, and then
out of BigQuery
we're able to do
machine learning.
We use some of that data,
again, for personal experiences
with App Engine.
It goes into the other GCP core
tools as Dataflow and Compute
Engine.
Dataflow we kind of use
really for how many people
are searching for a
route, and et cetera,
and we can really do a lot
of stuff with that data
there that comes in real time.
That's kind of how
it works there.
And then we'll go into a demo.
And I'll show you some of
the two products that we use
and how they're
used in real life.
So one of the dashboards that
our marketeers use quite a lot
is the Nationality
Flown dashboard.
I think we saw a demo of that.
The data itself has been
changed a little bit,
so for anyone that
wants to know,
we've changed all the airports
out so what you're seeing is--
in some of the
metrics out-- we've
changed some of that out,
so it's not real AirAs--
it's AirAsia data, but
the names are US names,
so it's very easy.
So, if you know
airport codes you'll
probably see very
familiar names here.
But this dashboard is
really used by marketeers
to go ahead and know
what type of people
are flying on a flight, what
is happening in terms of number
of passengers flown,
and typically they
were getting this dashboard
via email once a month.
And now, when we moved
it over to the BigQuery
engine and pipelines
that we have,
we're able to go ahead
and distribute this daily.
And customers, and er--
and clients can go ahead
and drill down and use this.
So I'll go to example here,
we have the date range,
but if I was interested in--
let's go ahead and
say MY nationality,
I can just click on that.
It's using the BI Engine in
the background and filters
everything pretty quickly.
And if I was interested in
this Fort Lauderdale route,
I can go ahead and click on that
and in subseconds it goes ahead
and change the data across.
Which is fantastic, because,
when you're in a meeting
you can refer to this
dashboard as the Bible
and everyone's looking
at the same thing.
So you can get up to
many, many users on it.
This is a copy of the real
one, so obviously there's
only one person on it right
now, but when we're in meetings
you can get up to, like,
a lot of people on it.
We have around a thousand folks
in marketing and commercial,
so you can imagine we can
get about 200 people looking
at this on a daily basis.
Not all concurrently, but
concurrently I usually see
around 50 to 60 people using.
And now with BI Engine,
the way that works,
it really makes it easy
and fast for people
to go ask that
question and leave
the meeting with real concrete
action items versus actually
waiting for a report back,
and asking a question,
and then having another
meeting on a report.
So it works quite well.
Let me just reset everything.
And you can see here,
as I filter along,
it's pretty responsive
and fast on how it works.
So it's quite impressive for us.
But, a lot of times,
the pre-cam dashboards
that we have aren't
enough for our marketeers.
They want to ask more
questions, right?
So the ultimate tool
that they use still
is a spreadsheet, right?
Because they want to see
some underlying data,
and they want to do a couple
more things, so what happens
is our BI teams that usually get
tasked with data pukes, right?
And the data puke is really
an extraction for information
because it's really
hard for them
to go write a SQL query
to get this information.
With the upcoming release
of connected Sheets,
we can go ahead and provide
a lot more self-service.
So this is a demo sheet
that we put together.
We'll look at some of the
questions that we have here.
And with some of the
questions is, it's great,
the dashboard looks great,
but we need something
more on capacity
impact slow, so I'll
show you an example of that.
In the dashboard,
it doesn't have that
very easily for someone to see.
It's there, but it's not
100% exactly in the form
that they want, and they'll
ask some particular questions.
So I'll just go through an
example of what they do.
The data that we're
going to use is--
we're going to use this
data set here, so let
me just go to the live one.
And you can see it's
around 12 million rows.
We have a lot of data sets that
are about 100 million rows as
well.
And then you can
imagine a marketeer will
have a tough time taking
this and putting this
into a spreadsheet.
It's just too heavy for
a spreadsheet to use.
So how do we solve that
with connected Sheets?
I'll try a brand new one.
So I'll just show
you the process.
So if you go to data, data
connectors, connected sheet
here--
let's see if it is fast enough.
There's a lot of people on Wi-Fi
here, so it's a little slow,
but we'll go to
our demo data set.
And so it's-- as you can tell
it's going straight against
BigQuery here, and
going against that,
and it actually
pulls the data here.
This is great.
This is the raw data.
It doesn't show you
all 12 million rows,
it just gives you an
idea of what's going on.
And then we'll go ahead
and do a pivot table,
as most marketeers want to do.
And the question that
they want to know
is, Fort Lauderdale,
how has it been growing
in terms of pax nationality,
and we can kind of
add that for the last two years.
So we can go ahead and add
some rows to show that.
And what we'll do here is group
it by month, add some columns,
and group it by year.
And we'll add in pax flown,
as that, was the question.
And then we'll add in a
filter that the text contains.
And so, if you know airport
codes, Fort Lauderdale is FLL,
I think.
I'm not really in the US
market, but I think that's it.
And if you hit the
apply button, it
does some magic
behind the scenes
and you get some
information there.
And you can see how
that actually flows out,
and you can ask more
questions very easily here.
But the magic behind this is,
really it did execute a query--
and if we go to
our query history--
whoops, should I refresh?
Yeah, let me refresh.
Hopefully it won't
take too long.
If it doesn't--
I shouldn't have refreshed.
I should have tapped it.
You can see here it did the
query that's here, and then--
if you-- previously this
type of analysis and work
would have required
a data analyst
to go ahead and write this
query for the marking guy,
and that causes a delay.
And then you have to go ahead
and prioritize some effort
here.
But, now, with
this type of work,
you're able to execute the query
on the fly in a connected Sheet
so that they can get
this type of information
very fast and easy.
And they can continue
on with their questions
without interrupting the
more complex work that a BI
analyst might need to go do.
So this is the next evolution
of data analysis at AirAsia,
and we'll be able to do a
lot more democratization
of the data that we've
already flattened and built
in BigQuery.
So that's the end of the demo.
[APPLAUSE]
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
And then what this really
means in terms of the impact
is we can use the data
in BigQuery to reduce
our operating costs,
like the example I told
you is really wastage on meals,
we can go ahead and solve that.
Zero hours in terms of managing
servers, we don't have to wait,
we are actually-- everything's
up and running faster.
Previously, in most ETL jobs, if
you're in the data warehousing
world, you only reprocess x
amount of days in history.
With the infrastructure
that we have in place,
I put two years of data,
but we can go many years,
and we can process
that in minutes.
Usually we can do the whole
ETL job very, very fast.
Historically, most
companies only
process seven years or 30
days of-- or seven days
or 30 days of historical
data on a run.
We can go ahead and
reprocess the whole cube.
So that allows us
to keep the raw data
and then go ahead
and run our ETL
pipeline so that we get faster
corrections or faster reports
out.
And then all of this
can be shared and used
by the 1,500 plus knowledge
workers that we have.
We have a lot of
folks that are running
the operations of the plane.
They don't need really access
to a lot of this raw data.
But, as we expose a lot more
data about customer behavior,
et cetera, we'll be expanding--
everyone will be able to
access a lot more information.
So, your cabin crew, they're
serving your hot meal,
will know your
preference, whether you
like a Coke or a Diet Coke.
You don't have to
ask that question.
They'll just give you
that beverage of choice
that you need, because that's
where people are expecting
that type of behavior.
If they've been ordering
Coke for the last five years,
you kind of know what they want.
So we can go ahead and
distribute this data a lot more
around the scenes there.
VINAY BALASUBRAMANIAM:
Well, thanks.
Thanks Nikunj.
NIKUNJ SHANTI: Yeah.
VINAY BALASUBRAMANIAM:
Thank you so much.
NIKUNJ SHANTI: Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
VINAY BALASUBRAMANIAM:
So what we just saw
was how AirAsia was able
to use the capability
of connected Sheets with BI
Engine scale [INAUDIBLE] a lot
more users within
the organization.
So, just to wrap it up, I just
want to provide a quick roadmap
update on where things are.
So, today, we are
announcing beta
with Data Studio for BI Engine.
The reservations-- that
we not turn on-- we're
not turning on billing so
you can use up to 10 gigs.
But, sometime in
July, we will turn
on billing where we have
give you more capacity
so you can decide--
you can create
bigger data models.
And GA is around Q4,
where we'll integrate
BI Engine with connected
Sheets as well,
so you get the same sort
of fast performance,
share the data model
within Studio and Sheets.
But, as I said earlier, we
take a very partner-oriented
approach in this as well.
So there will be an open API
which will be a simple SQL
interface, and we working
with Tableau, and Looker,
and other BI vendors, to
integrate this BI Engine
with other front ends as well.
So that's absolutely
plan in the roadmap
and that will be available
sometime early Q1, maybe Q4,
as well.
So, call to action, try BI
Engine, it's available for you
starting today.
You'll see that in
the BigQuery UI.
You can use Data Studio
to connect to that.
There's also a
session, I think right
after this, which talks about
all the new features of Data
Studio, how Data
Studio is evolving
as a visualization solution,
a lot of new features as well.
So I encourage you
to attend that.
We did have a session
earlier today on Sheets,
all the different ways
Sheets can be used.
So we have recorded
that, so do watch it.
And, also, when you're
in Asia, fly AirAsia.
Thank you all.
Have a great session.
[MUSIC PLAYING]